welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and she-hulk episode 1 established that
there's something very interesting
happening within the banner family
genome something about that banner
family blood be busted with the ability
to synthesize gamma radiation i hate
myself for saying that
and thanks to rocketmoney for sponsoring
today's video more about them later but
what could this mysterious family
element be i wonder like did the banner
family eat gamma green eggs and ham for
thanksgiving one year or something well
i think the answer to this lies within
the mcu multiverse specifically within
the first incredible hulk movie and no
i'm not talking about the incredible
movie from 2008 i'm talking about the
first hulk movie kevin feige ever
produced that pretty much no one really
talks about anymore angley's incredible
hulk film from 2003. that's right
everybody she hulk episode 1 has
secretly hinted that eric bana hulk is
canon in the mcu everybody so let's dive
into why i think this together my nerd
babies but first be sure to head on over
to newrockstarsmerch.com to pick up our
newest latest obsession shirts inspired
by both game of thrones and she-hulk
they're amazing but they're only going
to be around for a limited amount of
time so head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com today to pick one up
for you or someone that you love if you
don't have anyone that you love you can
buy two
[Laughter]
alright so in episode one of she-hulk
when bruce is giving a jolted jennifer
walters the cliff notes on how hulks are
made bruce mentions that something
unique about both their dna allows them
to synthesize gamma radiation granting
them the ability to grow and shrink
their physical mass at will you and i we
share a rare combination of genetic
factors that allow us to synthesize
gamma radiation into something else
so i
turn into a hulk now too as well as the
ability to you know not freaking die
from sad gamma radiation because you
know like tony stark mentions in
avengers 1 the amount of radiation that
bruce banner's head was exposed to
before his initial transformation into
the incredible hulk straight up should
have turned the brain of bruce into
freaking juice i read all about your
accident
that much gamma exposure
should have killed you well i think the
answer to this banner family blood
debacle could lie within the story of
angley in kevin feige's hulk movie from
2003 the very beginning of that movie in
fact specifically when the character of
david banner is introduced as a
geneticist who is obsessed with the idea
of using animal dna to help upgrade the
human immune system to be able to
self-regenerate the body you know kind
of like both general ross and samuel
stearns were obsessed with on earth 616
in the mcu however in angley's
neighboring universe general ross was
very much not a fan of the idea of human
test subjects unlike ross's variant
counterpart and he forced david banner
to shut down his experiments on the
human genome thus forcing this mad
scientist of a man in the making to run
his genetic experiments on his own self
a move that would ultimately affect his
newborn son bruce banner who inherits a
special genetic mutation from david's
now altered dna a genetic inheritance
that would ultimately save adult bruce
banner's life and vastly improve his
overall health after his gamma radiation
accident i believe that this event of
david banner altering his genetics is
significant and will factor into
she-hulk and he-hulk's stories moving
forward despite you know some minor
differences because if loki spider-man
no way home and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness proved anything
except the multiverse is filled with
variants with similar but ultimately
different stories so while i don't think
that ruffalo and norton's versions of
bruce banner have the same exact hulk
origin as eric bandus hulk i do believe
that there is a good chance that david
banner's influence on bruce banner's dna
could remain a constant you know kind of
like how the spider bite and the with
great power comes great responsibility
line is a constant for toby andrew and
tom's peter parker's they all happen
sort of differently but at the same time
they all happen and if this is the case
this could also serve to explain how
jennifer walters is also able to
synthesize gamma radiation despite not
being the daughter of david banner
herself because on the banner family
tree in the comics jennifer walter's
mother elaine banners walters is the
sister of bruce banner's geneticist of a
father and if mcu-616 david banner is
the same kind of dude that would be more
than willing to conduct experiments on
his own son behind his wife's back like
in the angley universe then it wouldn't
be too far of a leap to suggest that
elaine banner could have also been a
recipient of david banner's genetic
intervention especially considering that
in the comics she-hulk never actually
really got to have a relationship with
her mother as an adult because elaine
was killed in a car accident on her way
to see young jennifer at a dance recital
but in the mcu we see elaine alive and
well already trying to get her lawyer of
a daughter to dish out some avengers
level advice to some strangers named
yusuf who want to be a superhero i
wonder who that could be
i'm just kidding it's a completely
different use of it's not the same use
of it's not the same
now guys there are a lot of reasons to
save money maybe you want to save up to
buy a new nerdy shirt to show off how
much of a fan you are or you want to
take a trip to a con to show off how
much of a fan you are or you want to
remodel your house to look just like
stan lee's head to show off how much of
a fan you are because that's the only
way to do it really in the past if you
were looking to save money the best
option would have been to use trubill's
app to help with budgeting lowering
bills and tracking your finances but now
truebill is becoming rocket money
rocketmoney is everything you loved
about truebill with a fresh look and
feel rocketmoney lets you easily cancel
unwanted subscriptions with just a tap
you can also monitor your credit score
find out steps you can take to improve
your credit score and set budgets for
yourself there's even a tool to help you
set up a smart savings account to
automatically set aside money for
special occasions in case you're saving
up for a full body photo realistic
tattoo of stan lee's body to go on your
body i don't know anything about that
it's not me
it's not me don't look at my google
search history all right more than 3.4
million people use rocket money to help
get the most out of their money and you
can try out the new rocket money app for
free or upgrade to premium to unlock
more features want to see for yourself
simply head to rocketmoney.com new
rockstars and we thank rocketmoney for
sponsoring this video now because of
elaine's absence in jennifer's life in
the comics i think that there could be a
chance here that a life-threatening
situation could have also befallen
jennifer's mother elaine in the mcu
causing a fearful david banner to inject
his ailing sister with a similar
chemical compound to the ang lee help
film in order to boost her immune system
and save her life thus leading both
banner siblings to become parents
already as mutated human beings but this
all being said and since the marvel
multiverse is going full steam ahead in
phase 5 i'm predicting that this mention
of special dna within the banner family
is the first sign of kevin feige
canonizing his 2003 hulk film into mcu
continuity with no way home and
multiverse of madness as evidence marvel
seems pretty dedicated into bringing
pretty much all of live-action marvel
under the mcu multiverse umbrella in
some way and angly's hulk film is no
different i mean my dude kevin went out
of his way to include black bolt from
the very rough inhuman series in the
illuminati in multiverse of madness like
no one thought that was going to happen
no one thought we were going to see
anton mount as black bolt again but
kevin feige is the great redeemer so if
marvel is looking for a way to make the
path to secret wars a little bit more
fun while also capitalizing a bit on
that no way home nostalgia hype they
could do much worse than an eventual
multiverse crossover between banna
norton and ruffalo incredible hulks
ideally in a world war hulk scenario
because let's face it green violence is
fun but that is why i believe marvel
studios is planning to make all three
incredible hulk versions canon within
the marvel cinematic universe but what
do you guys think let us know in the
comment section below my nerd babies
because i love hearing from you thank
you guys so much for watching this video
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] you can follow me at mastertainment
on twitter because i between some weird
[ __ ] and theories all day long literally
all day long i have no other hobbies but
more importantly you can follow into
rockstars wherever we are on social
media and when you do on youtube make
sure you hit that notification bell so
that you can get notifications every
time we upload a video and of course do
not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com today so you can buy
all of our new latest obsession shirts
and when you do you get the opportunity
to leave a custom shout out that we
might read out on inside marvel or our
game of thrones after show it's a really
great way to support the channel but
again thank you guys so much for
watching this video i love you guys so
much and i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you